[Musique]
et me voilà dans la peau d'un apprenti
en mécanique aéronautique en compagnie
de mon instructeur d'un jour thiery
boissière bonjour bonjour nicolas
[Musique]
fait des formations en interne pendant
six à huit semaines les formations qui
vont aller sur dieu et c'est ceux de la
formation technique et de la formation
sur le côté pratique ça c'est un moteur
de livres c'est ça absolument c'est les
derniers venant de safran le leap donc
là c'est parti corzine qui est fabriqué
avec nos collaborations de mérite et non
concrètement qu'est ce qu'on apprend
comment ça s'apprend aussi mais bien sûr
est tellement facile il fait suffit de
passer par des instructeurs comme moi
par exemple aujourd'hui ou comprends les
gens avec la documentation que nous
avons en face là bas et on prend nos
utilisateurs gardent de travail ils ont
fait les opérations phase par phase et
on apprend en fait en pratiquant
absolument c'est le plus facile pour ce
type de machine parce que c'est de la
machine très lourde très lourde et très
complexe on va dire au niveau
technologie mature et alors tiré qu'est
ce que vous m'avez préparer aujourd'hui
eh bien nous allons faire le montage
d'un module sap a le goût du 53 sur le
corps du fn s'est produit ni pardon ni
par ses parties c'est parti
il suffit de prendre cet outillage
acheteurs prix nicolas
[Musique]
ah oui c'est relativement lourd quand
même
faire essayer donc on montre là haut il
rien le vice et 7e places voilà donc là
je monte sur l'escabeau absolument je
vous en prie
et donc il suffit de visser de vie c'est
mérité ça c'est quoi comme partie du
moteur ça c'est un guide uniquement et
ça permet de quoi en fait de positionner
voilà vous y aller tranquillement du
chemin voilà se suffira voilà ça suffira
voilà celle ci servira de guide pour
monter l'outillage pour centrer notre
module par rapport aux avantages du
corps on a un parti basse pression qui
est devant la sa partie haute pression
qui donne l'énergie au moteur pour
pouvoir faire tourner la partie basse
pression qui l'a 1 80% de la puissance
du moteur alors après cet outil de
guidage finalement la deuxième étape
c'est quoi et bien dit que là tu peux
venir avec moi je te accueillir on va
cet outillage et le monter directement
sur le module d'accord
donc là finalement ça ça va descendre
c'est ça ça descend aussi moi qui m'en
occupe
et on va directement le positionner sur
sur le club
et ça c'est quoi en fait c'est un
distributeur notant que c'est un
redresse les flux d'air chaud qui
viennent de la chambre de combustion
donc là j'étais préparée et nicolas
davis et des écrous d'accord c'est un
peu comme un meccano quand ils utilisent
des jeunes suffit de les mettre à
l'intérieur tout ça bouge un petit jeu
et après la vie c est au micro
c'est vrai que ça rappelle la jeunesse
on serre la main faut serrer fort
comment on serre la main mais pour
celui-ci
il
voilà c'est pas évident
hier le deuxième plus gros escrocs sur
un trop gros fun qui fait toujours un
tchèque pour voir si tout rond a fait
son travail correctement finalement la
sécurité fait partie intégrante de la
formation bien sûr il faut aussi faut
pas oublier le ss e sécurité et santé et
environnement aussi qu'il peut à partie
intégralement pour le salarié et pour
nos passagers et nos clients aussi aux
chèques le dernier les dernières mises
c'est en paix
[Musique]
voici donc après une fois qu'on a fait
le tchèque on peut leurrer la pièce
on fait un check visuels pour toutes les
pièces qui ont été montées du module
complet d'accord oui parce
qu'effectivement on voit davis à
l'intérieur mais bien sûr donc il faut
s'assurer que tout soit conforme au
montage final et toutes ces
vérifications se font à partir du plan
qui a sur l'écran absolument
documentation qui en réseau et qui a en
live bien sûr et la mise à jour se fait
au quotidien d'accord donc c'est notre
gamme de travail et nos instructions de
travail
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est
or je t'invite à monter là haut sur
nicolas
alors je monte
hélas falloir être rigoureux comme toute
phase de métier c'est de pouvoir aligner
le centrage de l'outillage avec le dit
que tu as mis en premier
l'assa 2 rue maillot
[Musique]
antoine sous peu
mais on vient se positionner directement
incertain
et là on peut virer pied en même temps
que le jeu et est bien maintenue en plus
de pièces
et bien bravo nicolas tu vas monter ton
premier module sur le leap merci thierry
pour ses explications je rappelle que
vous êtes instructeur pour safran
aircraft engines de saint quentin en
yvelines